this is the exclusive trillion dollar
company Club
it's made up of some of Tech's biggest
Giants and for a moment on May 30th this
company NVIDIA it's not a household name
but one day in late May Nvidia added
nearly 184 billion dollars in market
value
that's a single day sum worth more than
other companies in the semiconductor
industry and just a fraction of its
total value the company's record sales
have been fueled by an emerging
technology we're the world's engine for
AI here's how an under the radar
graphics processor is cashing in on the
AI craze and what's next for its
strategy
when Nvidia was founded in 1993 it
established itself as a leader in
graphic processing units or gpus for
video games
the company's powerful chips made images
crisper and less choppy nature of our
technology is to accelerate
multimedia applications for the consumer
in the years since the company's chips
have become an indispensable part of
many other products from PCS to cars to
robots Nvidia made a pivotal decision in
2006 but it started allowing software
developers to play with its gpus if you
want to be a trillion dollar company
you can't do just one thing kind of like
opening a door
um and once they open that door people
started to Tinker one of those
expansions was cryptocurrency mining the
company's gpus could handle the large
amount of computational power the task
required business flourished Rising
sales from the crypto Rush helped Nvidia
pass rival Intel and market value in
2020 but sales fell as crypto crashed
and the gaming industry slumped still
the chip maker was starting to see
another Frontier boom generative AI in
May sales of chips for the data centers
needed to power AI were up by 14 thanks
in large part to the growing need for
NVIDIA chips and AI calculations
for NVIDIA that was a decade in the
making the company's chips broke through
in the AI community in 2012 with a
neural network called alexnet we saw
early on about a decade or so ago that
this way of doing software could change
everything it was very futuristic it was
very uncertain at that point nobody knew
how big AI was going to be they made
that big bet when at a time when a lot
of other competitors were not making
that kind of bet we risked everything
to pursue deep learning Nvidia chips are
suited for powering AI because of their
ability to do lots of complex
computations simultaneously traditional
processing units can't do that as
quickly and other gpus like those from
Intel and AMD haven't gained major
market share in AI Computing if you
think about how Graphics work your
monitor your computer monitor has a lot
of pixels thousands of pixels on it and
your computer needs to calculate at any
given time what each of those pixels
need to look like it was discovered
fairly quickly after Nvidia kind of
opened up the door for people to use its
chips for other things that they were
actually really good at the kind of
mathematics that underpins artificial
intelligence in late 2022 AI exploded
with the public release of openai's chat
GPT and nvidia's stock skyrocketed while
companies like Google Microsoft and
Amazon battling out in the AI race
Nvidia is raking in the cache that's
because it's Chip's power most of them
for NVIDIA it's a bonanza all of these
folks who are competing to get a slice
of the generative AI Pi need Nvidia in
2018 the division that focuses on AI
computation made up less than half of
the company's sales by 2022 it was the
majority it went from Wall Street
expectation of 7 billion to Nvidia
saying actually going to make 11 billion
and so that really opened people's eyes
it was a real statement that you know
this generative AI craze that
everybody's talking about is more than
just a hype cycle but that success is
creating a different problem for the
company Supply the demand is literally
from every corner of the world the gpus
are
um this point considerably harder to get
than drugs
the company's supply chain hasn't been
able to keep Pace the the chip
manufacturing cycle is such that you
can't just immediately make more of
these things like today if you want them
the company says it has filled out some
of its Supply we are working on both
Supply today for this quarter but we
have also procured a substantial amount
of supply for the second half but the
Chip's Global demand has also caught the
company in the crosshairs of increasing
tensions between the U.S and China last
year the company said 400 million
dollars of its quarterly sales could be
subject to new U.S chip licensing
requirements for China in response
Nvidia began offering an alternative
chip to customers in China despite some
roadblocks the chip industry has its
eyes on nvidia's success they're still
riding this boom it's nowhere near done
the real question is whether companies
can build huge huge businesses that are
based on that artificial intelligence
capability
foreign